Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy. This
is Rawkode Live and I am your host
Rawkode.
I've now said my name three times in
ten seconds and I hate it.
Today, we are taking a look at an
open source project to bring continuous profiling to
everyone.
The project is called Parca and we are
joined by the CEO.
Hey, I turned that little video off.
Alright. I'm just gonna ignore it. I'm gonna
pop over here where I'm just put
myself off now. I'm joined by the CEO
and founder,
Polar Signals,
Frederic Brancic. Hey, man. How's it going?
Hey. Pretty good.
See, you know, I say at the start,
don't worry if things go wrong. It happens
all the time. It's usually me. In fact,
it's it's always me. I just break stuff
every single episode.
So thank you for for joining us today.
For anyone who's not familiar with yourself, can
you give us just a a little bit
of a hello and an introduction, and then
we'll take it from there? Of course.
Yeah.
First of all, thank you for having me.
So, yeah, I'm I'm Frederick. I founded
Polar Signals.
I've been part of the, like, cloud native
ecosystem
for, gosh,
six, seven years.
I was,
part of the,
I joined the Prometheus team in
twenty sixteen sixteen as a maintainer.
Basically, like, I think a a few months
after Prometheus had joined as the second CNCF
project
of all time.
So, yeah, I've been around for a while.
And as I said, Prometheus was kind of
my entry point,
but I kind of was in charge for
all things that connected
Prometheus and Kubernetes. And so to this day,
I'm actually still
maintainer for
the Kubernetes integrations in Prometheus.
And over time,
I I also I I co created, but
also eventually became the tech lead of the
special interest group for instrumentation in Kubernetes.
After, I think, four or five years of
service, I recently
handed off that that position to
make room for some new blood. But,
yeah,
kind of that that that intersection of Prometheus
or more generally observability
and
Kubernetes has been has been my thing for
a very long time.
I originally started doing all of this when
I joined CoreOS. I don't know if people
still remember CoreOS,
but
after the CoreOS acquisition by Red Hat, I
kind of stuck around at Red Hat for
a while. I became architect for all things
observability.
And kind of long story short is that
I eventually quit
Red Hat to found Polar Signals because I
felt like there was something about continuous profiling
that was worth pursuing.
Awesome.
Yeah. That's a a really good overview of
your history.
You're you're you've got one of those usernames
and faces that because you were so active
in the Prometheus
ecosystem and community. That, you know, I see
your little avatar on GitHub all the time,
and then,
yeah, you started showing up on a doing
a lot of KubeCon talks and other com
talks talking about observability instrumentation.
I think the Prometheus operator as well. It's
great to have you on the show and
I'm really looking forward to taking a look
at Parca and what you've been working on
for the last little while.
So I guess,
I've said that Parker brings continuous profile
but could we dive into that a little
bit more and just understand
what is Parca?
What are its main components? And and what
do people get out of deploying Parca to
their infrastructure?
Yeah. Maybe maybe before we dive into Parca
as a project itself, maybe let's talk a
little bit about continuous profiling because I think
it's still an emerging
methodology.
So
while hype hyperscalers have been doing this strategy
for almost a decade, it was pretty inaccessible
to to most other companies, and that that
is what we're trying to fix with with
the Parca project. But continuous profiling in its
essence is
basically that we always profile absolutely everything in
our infrastructure.
And
this is useful
because
because of the same reasons why we generally
do profiling of our software. Right? We want
to understand where our resources spend, where is
my CPU time spend, where is my memory
being spent,
where are my memory allocations happening, or, really,
you can
think of profiling data
as anything
anything pass that you can possibly think of
where you can you have a stack trace,
and you attach a number to it. That's
basically what a profile is. Right? Just a
collection of many stack traces
with a number attached to it.
In the case of a CPU profile,
it's how often have we seen this particular
stack trace, and we translate that to time
spent in that function.
And so as I said, CPU profiles is
something that is really interesting because CPU tends
to be the most expensive thing in
in cloud environments, but memory is certainly
a next contender or
network
network IO or, like,
disk IO. All of these are things that
contribute to cost.
And this is kind of a a good
segue to why why do people want to
do this? And the the most common answer
to that is people want to optimize their
cloud builds. And that's that's exactly why
companies like Google have been doing this kind
of methodology for over a decade.
They kind of identified, and I think it's
it's obvious once you say it. But once
you have that data about where your resources
are being spent down to the line number,
right, like, that's how granular profiling data is,
you can actually do something about it. If
you don't have that data, you just don't
know where to start.
And continuous profiling, as I said, is the
methodology of just always
doing profiling.
And there are a couple of things involved
in actually making that possible because
maybe maybe this is, like, something that's already,
you know,
a a question that was queued up in
your head. When typically, when we talk about
talk about or think about profiling, people immediately
think about overhead of profiling. Right? And
they wanna know, like, how much is doing
this actually going to cost me. Right?
And
the the answer to that is essentially
we
we we've developed a couple of
strategies
to reduce profiling overhead
so that we can always do this. And
there are there are kind of two
main things that are that are contributors to
this. One
is the type of profiling that we do,
and what we do is called sampling profiling.
And that essentially
we can think of it as how often
are we looking at this the current stack
traces, let's say, for a CPU profile.
And the obviously, the more often we sample
those stack traces,
the higher the overhead is going to be.
But we found that
for, like, looking a hundred times per second
is still
like, offers enough granularity,
at low very low overhead, something less than
a percent of overhead,
of a CPU core.
And the reality is,
once you have this type of data,
almost everyone we find has easy very easy
optimization
potential of, like, 10 to 30% of their
infrastructure.
So the trade off is, am I spending
1% overhead
to gain 10 to 30% optimization? I think
that's an easy calculation to make. Right? Yep.
Definitely.
There there was a lot of information there,
so thank you for for getting into that.
And you're right, one of the things that
I had on the back of my head
was like, what
am I paying for this for my own
infrastructure?
And you said the overhead is
I don't think you said negligible, but I'm
gonna throw that word out there. Just a
certain point where it's not that much because
of your sampling strategy,
which I think is is really interesting because
I think the more visibility people can have
into what's running in their clusters, it can
answer two of the hardest questions I think
people have in the Kubernetes space. Like, I
don't think there's been
a conference or a user group that I
went to where someone hasn't asked me, how
do I set resource
constraints on my pod?
I'm like, ah, yeah,
you have to profile your application and understand
what normal looks like. And it's just, it's
just quite a scary thing. I don't think
a lot of people have profiled their applications
before, well, probably ever.
And the second question is, how do I
debug
garbage collection and memory leaks and other things?
And again, you're back to the profile and
I was like, I'm sorry, you're gonna have
to learn this stuff eventually.
So it's nice to see that Parca can
come into this space and do the continuous
thing in a way that isn't gonna cause
too much overhead and just increase
that visibility without it being too daunting, too
scary, too to never acting like we're all
very careful, I hope, about what we deploy
to production. And there's my next question. Can
I run Parca in my production infrastructure, and
is that something that is encouraged?
Yeah. I mean, the
you you it's it's really just like any
other
observability data.
You can certainly run it in preproduction environments
or something, and we encourage that as well.
But in a in a similar line on
a similar note as, like,
your metrics are just never gonna behave the
same way in your local dev environment or
even a staging cluster.
It's always gonna be different in production, and
so you you're gonna always have to measure
these things in production.
Yeah. Definitely.
If you're trying to work at what normal
looks like in the staging environment, it's never
never gonna correlate to what you have in
your your real production environment. I couldn't agree
more. Yeah.
And
in in terms of, like, how production ready
is this this this,
like, open source project, let's say,
like, I think
it should be at least a little bit
taken with a grain of salt because it
is a very young project. Right? Like, it's
existed for maybe a couple of months.
But it's every week.
We we have an entire company working on
this and improving it. Right? Like, every week,
it improves drastically
from
literally every dimension. Like, on overhead, it continues
to improve.
On the storage, it continues to improve.
Yeah. Just on on every really really on
every dimension, which kind of, I think, is
also a good
point where we can talk about what you
said earlier, what makes up the Parca project.
Right? Because there are actually a couple of
moving components
that I think are good to understand.
So,
the Parca project,
largely, you can think of it as having
two components,
the server and the agent or the collector,
you could say as well.
The
the agent, the collector is the thing that
actually does the profiling part. It's the thing
that captures the raw data,
and then
batches it up essentially
and then sends that to the server, which
then stores it and where you can also
query it through its API and and UI
that is all integrated.
It's all very inspired.
At least the server part is very inspired
by Prometheus. It's probably not to a not
much of a surprise given my my background.
It like, we really focused on having this
extremely simple,
really great
first experience where it's a single statically linked
binary.
You know, all the container images exist. There
are, like, manifests available for Kubernetes.
Hopefully,
you know, your your first interaction with the
project is very, very smooth and very
simple.
Sweet.
Well, we're gonna take a look at it
in just one second. Before we do that,
I'll throw one more question
at you. Like,
it's it's an easy question, you know, but
no stress or anything like that. But I
feel like we're in a really great position
these days in the cloud native ecosystem,
you know, where Kubernetes is almost ubiquitous with
people. Maybe that's it's a good thing depending
on who you're talking to. But we're at
a stage where it's ubiquitous.
Almost everybody has a metric server. Everybody's got
a premium face. Everybody is doing some monitoring.
We're seeing a bit of a push with
observability and people looking at distributed tracing,
etcetera.
Do you feel that Parca is one of
these components that if you have a production
cluster, then Parca should just be installed? Like,
is that we looking at a project here
that we're saying to people, if you have
production infrastructure at this Kubernetes base, yes, you
must have this installed, like, next to your
Prometheus.
Absolutely.
The the whole point of or the the
the the reason that actually motivated me to
found an entire company around this is entirely
based on the premise that I believe that
this type of data is completely complementary to
your existing
observability
stack. As a matter of fact, kind of
I didn't know it back then, but I
think the seed for all of this was
planted in
a,
like, an invited keynote that I gave at
KubeCon in Barcelona
in 2019
where Tom Wilkie and I kind of gave,
he's the VP of product at Grafana now.
He and I kind of gave
an
a like, some guesses, let's say, what the
future holds for observability.
And part of that was
where where I predicted that I thought that
continuous profiling was going to become a major
player in the observability world simply because
it just like any other observability
type of data,
it gives you a unique kind of insight
into your running application.
It's unlike metrics. It's unlike tracing. It's just
just like metrics and tracing
are complementary to each other,
continuous profiling data is also complementary to to
those.
Sweet. I love that. You make a prediction
and then go out on a multiyear journey
to prove the prediction correct yourself.
It's it's as they say. Like, if you
wanna predict the future, you gotta build it
yourself.
Yeah. Perfect. That's awesome. Okay.
So we're gonna jump to the screen share
in just one second. We do have a
question from the audience, so I'll pop that
up on the screen and read that out.
But Ivan Ash is asking, can Parca also
collect metrics and be used for dashboards and
stuff, or do we need separate monitoring agent?
So it
it's not
exactly like metrics,
but you can think of it as a
super
high,
highly granular
CPU metric, for example. Right now, you probably
only have,
CPU being measured on a per process basis.
Maybe maybe if you're talking about Kubernetes, maybe
on a per container basis or on a
per per pod basis.
And in this this case, we would actually
be getting data down to the line number
and not just to the process, but also
with process metadata. And we'll see in a
second just how similar the experience
actually
is to to Prometheus
because the entire, like, labeling strategy of of
Parca is
very intentionally based on what Prometheus does. And,
hopefully, it'll all feel natural to
to someone who's already used Prometheus before.
Alright. Let's get straight over to the screen
share and get Parca deployed then.
Here we go. So this is parca.dev.
And we have the website, we've got some
basic instructions.
We have prepared upfront
Civo KCS cluster.
This has nothing installed. It wasn't installed out
the box by Civo, so we're starting completely
from afresh.
We'll jump back over here. So,
I mean, I could ask what the next
step is, but I'm going to assume it
is to install Parca.
Yes. Yeah.
Step one's always the easy one. After that,
I get a little bit I'm not as
confident with my predictions.
But so that's just let me zoom in
on this actually. Just
because some really simple instructions here for Kubernetes.
We're not using many cubes. I can skip
this.
We're deploying Parca to its own namespace. I
assume that's the preferred approach.
And then we deploy the two components that
you mentioned just a few moments ago, the
Parca server and a Parca agent.
I'm assuming this just runs as a daemon
set. This is a deployment. And by magic,
the thing just starts working.
Yeah. What I am curious about is, like,
when I deploy these, has the profiling started
already?
Yeah. So that's a that's a great question.
The the Parca agent, as we said previously,
is the thing that does the profiling,
and it actually starts to automatically profile absolutely
every container in your Kubernetes cluster.
It kind of discovers everything that's there,
and it uses eBPF
to attach an eBPF program
to
each of those containers. And that's essentially how
the entire construct of the profilers are built.
You said the magic words. Like, I can't
believe we're nineteen minutes seventy has just popped
up for the yeah. It's we're seeing such
a crazy adoption of that right now. It
just seems to be solving a lot of
these observability
and performance.
Not problems, but, you know, questions that people
have. It it it's it's funny because when
we when we actually founded Polar Signals,
we didn't really want to concern ourselves with
the collection side of the problem. We felt
like the
the majority of the value was in storing
and querying this data
in a useful way. But we pretty quickly
realized
that we were gonna run into kind of
two problems. The first one was the overhead
problem, which we kind of already talked about,
but eBPF kind of adds an additional benefit
here because everything runs in kernel.
And because we can collect exactly the amount
of data that we need and exactly the
format that we wanted in, it allows us
to do the profiling at actually an order
of magnitude less than,
quote, unquote, traditional
profiling techniques.
And there there are a couple of things
that maybe we can get into later that
kind of make this make up this strategy.
But,
yeah, eBPF has has definitely been a a
really amazing fit. And just the nature of
how eBPF works makes it really simple for
us to attach
these profilers to every container on a host
because
eBPF is literally
able to do anything or inspect anything on
the host. Right?
Yeah. We got that question from Moz, Ray,
and just as we started talking about eBPF.
But Moz was curious if it used eBPF,
and I hope that we've answered that for
you there, Moz.
Yeah.
Sweet. So
we've deployed the agent. We've deployed the the
daemon set, the no. The server and the
daemon set, which is the agent. Like, what
is the the way that we interact with
Parca? Should I go back to the docs
or should I just start guessing? Like
I mean, you can you can you can
hit the,
like, Parca in Kubernetes tutorial five five minutes
button, and you'll get the entire,
basically,
manuscript of what we're what we're doing here.
But you can check out here, you see
the,
like, a port forward.
We don't make an opinion of we we
don't wanna take an opinion of how people
are gonna expose this. You know, you can
put an ingress here or
Yeah. I don't know. Whatever your preferred way
is. Right? So here, we're just telling people
to do port forward.
Alright. Well, we have a three node clusters.
We have three agents. We've got the server.
We could do a port forward to the
service on seventy seventy.
And let's see.
Hey. We have Parca. It worked.
The fir first first feature
that's always had the most important to people
is, on the,
top right, you can see the little toggle
for
dark mode.
It was actually one of the first feature
requests that we got. So, yeah, definitely important.
But no. It's always nice when you go
to a blog, though. Right? And you see
that little sun and moon in the top
corner, and you're like, oh, good. I can
set my own preference. Like, I think as
developers, we get a lot of pleasure from
the simple things like that. So it's good
to see.
Yeah.
So
when when you when you start and this
is actually something that we're actively trying to
improve that you don't need to know how
to use this just yet, that you immediately
see some data. But for now, this is
how how it works, and you start by
selecting the type of profile
that you wanna see. And right now,
the
the Parca agent only supports
CPU profiling.
We're we're going to be adding more of
this, but
the the entire
Parca project is
actually
based around an open standard called pprof. This
was a format that, Google had originally created
for,
representing profiling data, essentially.
And anything that is p professor formatted can
be written to the Parca storage.
And so in this case, we're only sending
CPU samples, but there are integrations. For example,
the Go runtime itself has support for various
types of profiling,
like memory
profiling,
Go routine profiling,
and you can also ingest
those profiles into Parca. In this case, we
are only running the Parca agent, though.
Okay. So I just select on CPU samples
here? Yep.
And then You could already hit hit search
at this point, and you'll start to see
some data.
Yeah. Yeah. Like a graph. Nice.
So now we can already see some some
similarities to Prometheus here.
If you if you hover over a dot,
for example, you'll see that there there are,
like, labels attached to this series of profiles.
So here we have the Parca
container itself
and the idea of it, its namespace, the
node that's running on, and the pod.
And you can hover over each of them,
and whenever you're to a closest to a
point, it'll tell you
what what container
we're looking at.
You can also while you hover over something,
maybe it's maybe a little small for the
audience to see, but it says hold shift
and click a label to add to query.
So if you hold shift while you're hovering,
you can now click one of these,
let's say, the names Parca namespace, for example.
Then it filters everything
down, and you can see that our query
was updated
in the query bar.
And now we're only seeing
processes
from the Parca namespace.
Cool. And so so far, we're only seeing
metrics,
basically. Right?
But we actually wanna see profiling data. So
what we could do now is any of
the dots that you were hovering over, once
you click them,
you'll see
and you you need to scroll down,
then we'll see
Oh, yeah. Clean graph.
So this is showing me I always I
should have paid more attention to what I
was clicking on. I think I clicked on
this. So this is the
Parca container.
So this is actually the Parca server container.
Okay. And this is all the server itself.
All the functions being called within the application?
Yes. Exactly. At that point in time. So
At that point in time. The the the
profiles are always taken over a ten second
interval.
And so
within those ten seconds,
of which the,
profile of of the profile's time stamp,
these are the things that were being executed
during that,
that time.
And there's something that I I I've been
incredibly
excited about ever since we first implemented this.
If you scroll up,
you can see that there's a compare button
next to the search button
in the in the bar. Yeah.
So what this now does
is it it should open
maybe oh, yeah. No. There we go. So
what we can now do is we can
compare
two profiles
in their points points of time. So for
example,
on the left hand side,
select one of the Parca profiles that, you
know, isn't at the peak,
Maybe from the green one. Yeah. That that
one. And then on the other one, select
the one at the peak just after that
or that peak. It doesn't really matter. And
now you can see exactly what was worse
in the in the comparison of these two
profiles. In this case,
the the the comparison was quite drastic,
so we're seeing a lot of red. Right?
But if it's if it's more nuanced, we
can see exactly what was different.
And,
again, in this case, it's quite drastic, so
all of the red is pretty dark,
but it's actually shades of red
that are telling you what got how much
worse.
So I I'm curious. Like, I'm, you know,
an application developer. I'm shipping multiple times per
day. Would this compare feature allow me to
compare
a standard profile from one version against the
profile and the new version I've shipped to
see if I've got performance gains or or
or maybe things have gotten worse since I
went ahead?
I'm I'm glad you asked.
For for for for answering that question, let's
take a step back and talk about one
more thing that kind of makes
continuous profiling so great.
And for that, if you just hit profiles
at the top, this kind of just resets
our
our query. So if you
select
CPU profiles again
and then maybe filter just down to the
Parca container, if you want, you can hit
search and and then click the click the
label, or you can do a,
label search.
Yeah.
So now
other than,
compare and search, what we're seeing in the
in the search bar, there's also merge.
And what this does
is it takes
all the points in time that we've collected
over the entire time of this process,
and it compiles everything into a single report.
And this is really, really cool because not
only does it tell us where CPU time
was spent at a single point in time,
but actually it tells us statistically
over the entire lifetime of this process where
CPU was CPU time was being spent. And
so
the consequence of that is that once we
look at that report
and we can we can optimize something in
that holistic report of our entire
process's lifetime,
if we can optimize something from that, we
will actually
reduce CPU time of the entire
process process's lifetime. Right?
So that's how we'll actually do significant
cost savings.
K. So should I click the merge button?
Yep. Hit it.
So now now we we see all of
the data of the entire
time that the Parca process has been
alive,
and we can we can explore
where that CPU time was being spent as
opposed to just a single ten second profiling
time.
Cool.
I like that. That's very interesting.
And
now now coming back to
the question that you had
Well, can I ask you a and I
really
Your your question was
to to to come back to your question,
which was, can I essentially
compare
two versions
after I kind of deploy them? Right? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. And the answer the answer to
that is yes. And but not only
a single point in time, but you can
actually
compare the entirety
of two versions. So not just
this
this process at this time and this process
at that time, but, no, you can actually
merge all of the data of a single
version of a of a program
and compare those two versions.
So finally, we'll be able to answer down
to the line number
what was different. Why did why is this
thing using more CPU now after I deployed
it compared to previously?
Or why did it get better? Right? All
of these things that previously,
as engineers, we were kind of guessing,
Now we actually have the answers.
Alright. Awesome.
This is really cool. I think this is
absolutely game changer.
Now
we've got one question from Russell in the
chat, which we'll tackle in a minute. But
I also wanna tackle something,
like, just one one of the really simple
things here that not everyone may be familiar
with this graph and what this is what
this is displaying and what it means and
why things are are duplicated.
Could you give us the the one zero
one for this flame graph and what that
means?
Yeah. So as you already said, this visualization
is called a flame graph.
And the way that we read it
is that from actually, this is called an
icicle graph,
which is the upside down version of the
flame graph. The flame graph is built from
bottom up like a flame. Right? But the
icicle graph is icicles hanging from the ceiling
just like the one that we're seeing here.
Today, love Yeah.
I, you know, I I created the brand
Polar Signals without even knowing this, and then
afterwards was, like, like,
a happy little accident.
But, yeah, coming back to how to read
this, essentially, the very top bar, the root
describes all
CPU time that we're looking at. And then
every span
that we're looking at
underneath it is relative to that total.
And so
if there is a span in here
that we can optimize,
it means that the
width of it will,
that will be the effect that it will
have on the entirety of our program. So
let's say one of the larger,
spans that we see in the middle here,
if we're able to
optimize
that, we can actually and you can hover
over it. It tells you the percentage as
well. If we can optimize that away in
this case, it's 90%,
but, right, the further we go down, the
less it gets because it's kind of cumulative.
But if we can optimize this one away,
for example, we will be saving 36%
of our of our entire process.
And
the more we do this,
the more effect we see on on our
cloud bill.
But there are actually a couple of other
use cases that I think are also good
to talk about
when we when we think about profiling or
continuous profiling.
Obviously, cost savings is one that we've talked
about several times by now, but I think
there are kind of two more that a
lot of people find very compelling.
The the the
kind of helping you with latency optimizations
because latency
tends to be we we tend to be
able to if we're this advanced,
we may be able to detect
where latency problems exist in our
in our system with tracing data, but tracing
data is actually very high level. Right? It
doesn't tell us anything about the lines of
code that we need to optimize.
Yep. Combining that with profiling data
is actually incredibly powerful,
and we've worked with, like, ecommerce companies that
are optimizing their latency
through this type of data.
And
if you might know,
ecommerce companies have this kind of
target to have every interaction in their system
be less than a hundred milliseconds because that
drives conversion.
Because we humans like things to feel
instant,
and that means that we're more likely to
purchase something on a website.
So that's kind of
in the in the grand scheme, that's
use case number two, and it tends to
be actually a much bigger motivator for companies
to make more money than just to save
money. Right?
But go
ahead. Would it be fair to say you
know, we're talking about cloud native and microservices.
You know? Hopefully, the people watching have a
little bit of experience with distributed tracing. And
like you said, it gives you the latency
response time from service to service communication. Is
it fair to think of profile as tracing
at the function level, exposing individually within services
what is actually happening on that call stack?
Yeah. Yeah. That that is entirely
accurate.
The the difference is that it's not across
services. It's only within a process.
But we're we're actually working on a couple
of correlation
techniques so that we can tell you, for
example, all of the CPU time that was
spent
with a particular trace, for example, so that
we can jump from a trace to profiling
data.
This is not something that works yet, but
we have a couple of strategies
that we're exploring to to make something like
that work.
Right.
But yeah. And then then the the last
use case that I was talking about is
kind of I I think we sort of
touched on it already,
but I think it can be generalized
as
incident response.
Right? Because we have this data of what
our processes are executing down to the line
number,
we can actually answer some of the questions
that
we as engineers have kind of or at
least I myself have been asking myself ever
since before I I had a tool like
this, which is, like, why was my process
spending
CPU time or, like, a had a CPU
spike here and not here?
And almost always, as we as you said
earlier, it's GC,
garbage collection.
But,
yeah, sometimes it's more it's more surprising than
that
or with memory. Right? Like, why did my
process use more memory at this point in
time versus this other point in time?
Yes. Definitely.
Alright. Let's tackle the questions we have in
the chat, and then we'll jump back to
our demo here.
And
we got a hello, just done with the
Parca office hours from Mathias.
We
got okay. Question for Russell.
Did you say it profiles everything,
I e the API server? And if so,
does that work on cloud hosted Kubernetes instances
where the control plane is managed by the
cloud vendor?
So
probably for most of the
cloud vendors that you're thinking of,
because
we can't get the Parca agent to
to get deployed on the
wherever the the API server runs.
Basically,
as as long as we can get the
Parca agent to be on the same host
as something, it will be able to profile
it.
As a matter of fact, we're actually thinking
about a couple of strategies where we can
expand
the things that we're profiling to not just
be the containers
on a on a system, but actually every
process on that system.
Because
I think I think it's kind of obvious
once we say it, but there can be
other interactions
with processes on a host that are not
running in containers. Right? Maybe they're system d
units, or maybe they're not running in c
groups at all.
So,
yeah, hopefully, that answers the question.
Yeah. I think so. We also got another
one from Mozz.
Compare
the CPU time consumed by a specific function
run on two different containers or different nodes.
Yes. Absolutely. That's that's exactly what the compare
functionality
does.
We're also working on
being able to filter down
the stack traces to not only compare by
container or by process,
but actually down to the stack trace so
that you can say, I only wanna see
data about this one function, and then you
can compare it exactly the way that it
was phrased in the question. Right now, you
would compare two whole profiles,
and you would need to find the specific
function that you're looking for, but we're absolutely
working on
on this specific use case already to support
it even better.
Awesome. Thank you. And we'll tackle this last
one that came in from.
Do we only get CPU profiles
there?
So great great great question. So
I think I I mentioned it
earlier very
briefly, but the entire Parca project is based
around the open standard p professor. And any
p professor formatted profile can be written to
the Parca storage and can be visualized and
analyzed in the same way as we're doing
with this data. So as a matter of
fact, the
Parca agent also produces pprof compatible profiles
and then sends those to
to the Parca storage. And so as long
as you can produce profiling data in the
pPRA format,
you can write it continuously to
to the Parca storage.
So
there there are lots of profilers out there.
As I said earlier,
the
the Go runtime has support for memory profiling,
for
allocation
profiling,
for threads being created, for Go routines,
for mutex contention,
for a whole lot of things.
And all of those can be written to
to the Parca storage and can be analyzed
in the same way. So these are these
are profiles that you plan to support in
Parca. They're just not quite there yet?
So you there there's there there are kind
of two ways to ingest data today
into into Parca.
The first one is pushing the data, and
that is exactly what the Parca agent does.
Whenever it has a profile ready, it just
sends it to the Parca storage.
And the Parca server
actually also supports
scraping profiles in the same way. You can
think of it very similar to what Prometheus
does, where Prometheus has its metrics endpoint, and
it scrapes the metrics from that endpoint every
fifteen seconds.
Parca can actually do exactly the same thing
with p professor formatted profiles.
Ah. And so
I think, actually, this might be a a
great time to have a have a look
at that.
What you can do is you could
go back to the parka.dev
website,
and we can switch from the
Kubernetes
deployment to the binary because then we can
just have Parca scrape itself
because Parca
is instrumented with a whole lot of profiling,
and then we can have a look at
those profiles as well.
Yeah. I I think that's quick. I don't
wanna
make too many assumptions, but I think it's
quite normal in the goal ecosystem, right, to
have p professor embedded in your brain. Right?
I I remember when I was working on
InfluxDB, we had to debug slash p professor
endpoint,
which exposed a whole bunch
of information. And you're saying that Parca can
just consume that right away if you tell
it where it is? Exactly. Yep. Okay.
Alright. So let's jump back over here. So
if I go back to the start and
the binary one
Yep.
Just gonna work on a
m one Mac?
That is a great question.
Let's find out is the answer.
I do not think so.
I think it is. That that looks like
it works.
Amazing.
Nice. Alright. Great. So now we get the
basic configuration and just run Yeah. Parca.
Do mind if I just quickly take a
look at this? Yeah. Go ahead. Alright.
So
It looks like a Prometheus config.
Yeah. It it literally
reuses Prometheus code.
Alright. So you just define the the script
configs. So I'm assuming these targets could be
anywhere I know there's a container or a
pod, an application that exposes p professor endpoints
and Parca just pulls them in. Right? Okay.
And assuming I just go to seventy seventy
local host and Yep.
You still have that open, so let's just
refresh.
Is this my old one? I think maybe.
Not seeing what I expected to see.
Yeah. That that still looks like our Cboe
cluster.
Yeah. Yeah. This is too much data.
We we
that's definitely not But I'm not port forwarding
anymore. I'm confused.
Am I? No. Oh, I am.
So did this
Is this maybe a virtual machine of some
sort?
No. Uh-uh. Well, my port forward was still
running, and so I actually would have expected
an error message Yeah.
I I I did as well.
Oh, there we go. Okay. Yeah.
Now it works.
Yep. So now you can see these are
all the types of profiles
that
Parca scrapes from itself.
Yeah. So I think, like, memory in use
is a in use bytes is a nice
one to look at.
Search.
Let's get let's give it a couple of
seconds because
it's not writing
a whole lot of data. Right? Like, it's
only about itself.
Yeah. So what what was the do we
define a scrape interval in that config? I
wasn't Yes. Yeah. Okay.
I don't have my history there. So that's
just I can tell it to scrape profiles
on a more regular cadence that kinda just
just start up. Is that worth doing, or
do you think we just wait ten seconds
there?
You can just hit search again, and there
might already be Yeah. There we go. So
now you could do the compare,
and we could figure out exactly why this
jump happened. Right?
Yeah. And
we can see Badger created a bunch of
skip lists.
Yep. New skip list.
Well, I'm not sure why that there.
This so you're scoping essentially
the there this is essentially interacting with the
with the flame graph.
And once you found something that you're interested
in, you can see on the left hand
side, for example, there are a couple of
spans that are too small to read.
You may you you can
click on one of those, and it'll expand,
and then you'll see Ah. All of the
rest of of its child nodes.
Okay.
And, essentially, everything that's,
like, faded out is the part that we're
kind of zooming in on. Right? And from
there on,
the root essentially becomes whatever we clicked on.
Okay. Does
it
like, this is a a runtime dot do
in it function.
Like,
can I find out how many times this
was called? Like, if I had maybe a
recursive function that was going about wild in
my application, is Parca
would I be able to show that in
some way, or would it just be as
I would see it called lots on the
on this on the call graph?
Yeah. So
this depends a little bit on the
on the profiler itself. Typically, profilers have some
sort of
limit on the stack depth.
This tends to be
sixty four
sixty four frames, something like that.
So
that's that's how often you would see it
repeated, and then at some point, it would
stop if it's, like Okay. Endlessly recursive.
Yeah.
Okay. So I wanna make sure that
I understand this right. So we're using a
different profile because it's been scraped over HTTP.
We're looking at the memory and just bytes.
We can see the graph, which has shown
us how much memory was allocated to two
different points, which is great.
We have these red things, which I'm assuming
is telling me that these functions are consuming
memory
Yeah. On the stack.
Mhmm. Alright. Okay.
I mean, is there a size?
Like, I can see we have a figure
here. I know that we're using a 20
meg, but does it show me more specifically
which one of these functions is the the
bad actor here if that was, again, a
memory leak or something else? Yeah. So you
you always wanna look at the
deepest
span
that
doesn't have any children anymore.
So we can actually tell here that new
skip list is actually the thing that allocated
the memory here. So if we optimize new
skip list
in this case, we're intentionally preallocating memory, so
it's not actually a bad thing. But let's
say it was.
If we optimize new skip list to
if we if it was truly possible
to just not do this at all, we
would actually save
70%
of our memory
almost or 67667.81%
of our memory. Right? Okay.
So yeah. And
I think
maybe this is a bug, or we need
to update the version.
But
we see the cumulative and the difference number
here.
We know actually that this,
data that we're looking at is
bytes,
so it would,
it should be,
formatting this as, I I wanna say this
is, like, 87 megabytes or something, but maybe
I'm wrong. No. I think that's right based
on what we've seen here. 40 to a
20. So, yeah, you're pretty much spot on.
So, yeah, it it looks like in the
in the graph, it's working. Maybe we have
some bug in the
in the front end about the
hover state.
Okay.
Don't mean to put you on the spot,
but would you wanna give us, like, the
TLDR for these different profiles and and maybe
what they're useful for to people?
Yeah. Absolutely. So
these are these are very specific to Go.
Right? These are
profilers that are built directly into the Go
runtime. So these are definitely going to differ
for different languages,
different run times,
but I think they're still really useful and
interesting to know. So
block contention,
basically, hopefully, the descriptions of of each of
the profiles underneath
are descriptive enough. But,
essentially, whenever we have a
blocking
primitive
being called,
that's when we record that stack trace that
we understand
where does our where in in what paths
of our program
is our program being stopped and can can
no longer do something. And in the Go
case, this is actually particularly
interesting because the Go runtime
tries to
move
Go run Go routines around
to
prevent
Go routines from actually or threads from actually
blocking.
So this is a really useful one to
know if for what for some reason,
go routines keep being scheduled onto different threads
all of the time,
which would create a performance problem.
Go routines being created, definitely
a very
easy mistake to make. And, certainly, in the
Prometheus project, we've
we've,
like, fallen into that trap many times where
we leak Go routines. We just keep creating
them. They never end.
And a go routine means
we create a new stack every time,
which ends up costing memory,
and then we'll we'll we'll eventually see it
in both our go routine profile as well
as our memory
in use bytes profile that something is using
a bunch of memory and ends up
could end up being the go routines being
created.
The next one is memory allocations.
So we need to differentiate here. The one
that we were looking at previously was the
heap size. So how much memory
is currently
in use. Right? Like, how much when we
look at top or something, how much of
that
how much memory are we using currently?
And then allocations
are
how much l memory has been allocated
over the entire
lifetime of our process.
And, again, this is a really useful thing
to understand
because allocations
tend to be where we spend a lot
of our CPU time.
I I it's definitely a generalization,
but a lot a lot a lot of
the
optimizations
that we see
are simply preallocating
some memory instead of
allocating them in small bytes,
like, one after another.
Then memory and use, we kind of looked
at already, and I I talked about just
now as well. Yep. Mutex contention is definitely
an interesting one as well.
In in case it's not well known, I
think, like, outside of the go go community,
maybe c plus plus engineers understand
this, but, like, single threaded
environments like Node. Js
or often in Ruby, these things aren't used
either, maybe in Python.
But
mutexes are essentially a synchronization primitive
where we can say someone has the exclusive
right to some piece of memory.
And
this is great in terms of writing safe
code,
but it can also lead to con contention
when multiple
threads want to or go routines in the
go case want to write to the same
thing,
and that means that they're blocking each other
and, you know, creating latency potentially in the
system or worse,
maybe even deadlocks if if it never gets
freed, the the mutex.
And then the last one that we see
is CPU time, which is something that we
already looked at earlier. So, literally, where was
CPU time being spent in that process?
Awesome. Thank you for that. You are a
wealth of knowledge.
Alright. So, Matthew, in the comments, has double
checked the release for 07/01 and confirmed that
the accumulative value for formatting is indeed broken
and will open an issue. There you go.
Great.
Alright.
Is there anything else that you want to
look at before we deploy the microservice
demo thing?
Is there anything we've missed from the from
the UI or functionality from Parca that you
wanna show off before we do that?
I think the only thing that we we
kind of
glass just glanced over, but something that I
was quite excited about because this was something
that we didn't have in Prometheus for the
very longest time,
which is autocomplete of the
of the queries. So if you go back
and click on profiles again,
we can see that we have autocompletion for
the label names.
And, actually,
behind all of this is an entire
language
of writing these
queries,
and it's very similar to the Prometheus
Prometheus query language.
But we kind of have a real parser
in the front end here that takes the
query apart and does suggestions
based on where your where your cursor is.
Right now, it actually only the the suggestions
only work for
label names as well as,
like, constants,
and you you'll you'll see what I mean
by constants. If you, let's say,
choose instance
and then
equals or what whatever, really, and then you
do
two quotes
after the equals.
And, yeah, now you can see that that
comma was being suggested, right, because that is
logically the next thing that should follow after
this.
So, yeah, I I I was pretty excited
about this primarily
because I haven't written a parser,
since, like, my
compiler's class in university, I think.
But, yeah, I think this is pretty cool.
And, obviously, the next thing that we're building
here is that we have labeled value completion
as well. Yeah. That would be awesome. I
just appreciate the auto complete when we started
clicking onto the boxes and stuff.
Yeah. Been able to do that on the
values themselves would be a really, really nice
touch. Yep.
Yep. It's in progress.
A lot of the plumbing actually already exists.
Nice.
Alright.
So
I prepared a small kind of microservice thing
in Go that I I found on GitHub.
So this is by the user Harlow,
and it's just, like, for Go based microservices
that display some hotels on a map. They
use gRPC to do communication and I thought
it'd be good to see profiles across that.
Before
I knew anything about Parca, in fact, well,
I was even pronouncing Parca wrong, a whole
hour ago, is that
I didn't know the compare feature existed.
And now I'm kicking myself because we missed
an opportunity to actually use it as part
of the demo that I wanted to show.
But I'm thinking that we're trying to be
brave here,
which never works out well for me. So
the only thing I added to this project
was a whole bunch of YAML to do
the deployment here.
I really I
really naively used the latest tag,
but I'm hoping if I do an image
list,
is that we'll still have the content addressable
one that I pushed earlier.
So
I think I'm gonna update as Yowl to
deploy the old one before I added the
bug for you to find, to see if
that can help us do Yeah. Okay. So
I've injected like a little bit of CPU
intensive code into one of the services and
we wanna see if we can debug and
discover that.
So this is the fun bet though. The
first time I built this, I built up
the platform argument. So this should be the
one that won't work at all.
Then because it's an M1 Mac, it doesn't
deploy my Kubernetes cluster, which is not
Arm 64. So I think we need to
deploy this one.
How do I get
the actual shaft from that?
You might be able to check out the
registry where you pushed it to, and we
might be able to
find just enough of the SHA.
I think if you click on the tag,
there's a, like,
a history or something sometimes.
Maybe that maybe only
does that.
Alright. Well, let's there must be a way
to show this chat here.
Yeah. Digest. There we go.
And we'll make sure this matches up. So
the current one is 944,
which is this one,
which means this one here should be my,
before I broke the code.
So if I go into my Kubernetes folder,
replace latest
with
the SHA,
do you need the at symbol? I can't
remember. Yes. You need the the at symbol,
and you actually need to write sha two
sixty
five colon as well. Yeah. Okay.
And we wanna do that in the start
of the ML.
I guess.
I'm I'm I'm feeling how to say it
now. That dash I s search replace. Yeah.
It should just be filename. Right? Let's just
front end on its own.
I I think I think there might be
a thing where,
you know, maybe the at symbol or the
colon does something with the
with the regex. I I I'm never too
sure either.
No.
Not in the replacement side. If it was
on the matching side, definitely. I see. Yeah.
Yeah. You're right. But there, I think it's
alright. So this is just me
not remembering
that which
just put the failure.
So
I is unlined. Maybe we need the e.
There's the I e.
There we go.
Welcome to the said beginner's guide for idiot.
I'm the idiot. But now we have the
colon for the app.
Alright. I'm gonna open it if you ask.
Good. Okay. So
we just need that. Right?
Yeah.
Yeah. I don't need to
do
said failure.
Alright.
At this
profile service.
At this.
I'm waiting for someone in the chat to
tell me what my my mistake was. Sometimes
it's just quicker to do it
the boring way.
So let's do a cube control apply
star.
What?
Okay.
Dot.
There we go. No. I can't even remember
cube control.
Okay.
Maybe I got that wrong.
Well, it works for front end. Oh, no.
Because I alright.
See, I told you whenever anything goes wrong,
just blame me. Always me. I forgot the
five six on the other ones.
I see.
Alright.
I wish I had just deployed that straight
up now. But
if this works and we see the difference,
I'll be very excited
and apply.
Okay. That is going to work.
Yeah. We can already see them starting to
run. Yeah. Nice. Now because we have the
server and the agent already deployed,
if I do a port forward, we should
be able
to see
k. Port. There we go.
I'm not that the front end.
Well, I guess we probably
no. We don't need traffic yet. We can
just
Parca.
We could just go to here and we
should see data already.
Wonder if I need to shut down the
other one.
Cool.
Looks good.
So let's take a look at the default
namespace.
I got a new keyboard and I can't
type.
Cool.
Is that right? Yeah. Yeah. That looks right.
Yeah. So we can see Jager in front
end. I expected to see a few more
containers.
Now it could just be that this
oh, no. I'm on the wrong cluster.
There we go.
There we go. So it could just be
the sampling hasn't kicked in for the the
other ones which started a little bit late.
So if we hit search again, we get
more colors.
Yeah. Cool.
This application is
nice and simple.
We could browse to local host on port
8080.
It could also be so if if there's
absolutely no CPU
time being spent, obviously, there's nothing to measure.
So that could be
what we're seeing as well. It depends on
what these services do.
Ah, okay.
Well, every time I zoom around, this is
the the back end of this application is
talking to each other and checking and searching
for new spaces. When I click on these,
that's the profile service.
So we should see
in a little bit of time that we're
gonna get more information.
However,
I think if we just go straight ahead
and deploy the broken one now and interact
with it, we should see a,
hopefully,
spike in the CPU.
Yep. So
try and keep those two running just now
and go back to here
and undo.
Cool.
I dash f go.
Is that the wrong cluster again?
Yeah.
I swear I know what I'm doing. I
promise.
Alright. So we got some new containers coming
up. We'll let that switch over. We'll let
Parca do it saying, get some profiles and
and then we'll see if you can just
guide me through the process of debugging which
service
has given us some problems. And hopefully,
hopefully it works.
Cool.
Alright. So we got a comment from Mattias.
This is where the fun begins.
I certainly wasn't finding my skills are particularly
fun, but hopefully, this works.
Moz is telling me to use the hash
symbol to escape the at char.
I still don't think we have to skip
the at char because it was in a
replace state, but then I've just shown them
my set skills are not exactly up to
date. So we'll see.
It might be that
at
can be used
for selecting a grouping or something
of the first
Yeah. I mean, you could be right. I
can't remember.
There there are a lot of different I
know dollar sign allows me to pull things
from the match, but,
yeah, maybe you you could be right.
Okay.
Let's
click search.
Okay, we're getting more data. So let's,
I need to report forward again.
So this is the new version.
If I zoom in a few times, click
a few buttons,
and
we I guess we just cannot oh, there
we go.
That may be related potentially.
I think we should get a refresh every
ten seconds button. Is that is that a
good feature request?
Yeah. Actually, it's already in progress.
Nice.
Okay.
So
we potentially have enough information to debug here.
Do you wanna kinda guide us what you
would do if you were actually trying to
work out what was wrong in this system?
So in in this case, I wanna say
we're probably
like, we see this spike that we didn't
see before. Right? And I I think I
saw that the profile container is what was
the contender here. Mhmm. So let's
filter down by that container. So if you
hit shift again,
you can
click that label again. Yep. So now, basically,
do you can go to your compare view.
This is and I just wanna point this
out because if this is are these colors
to show different deployments of the same
container?
Yes. Exactly. Sweet. So I can actually already
see exactly when that's swapped over and then
the contention happened on the CPU. So that's
cool. Yeah.
And
if
if there was a
particular label that also kind of
distinguished
the two deployments,
in this case, we don't really have that.
We have the
container ID, which we could, you know, abuse
for the same purpose. But, ideally, we would
have a
or
something that is means something to us as
the developer.
Then we could,
once we go into our compare view, we
could actually filter down to to seeing only
those,
points of data.
But in this case,
the the the just selecting a point in
time will do the same
will have the same effect.
So what you can do is you can,
on the left hand side,
select one of the profiles,
maybe the one that has a couple of
I'm just I'm just trying to see how
back I can get the graph.
Okay.
Give that ten seconds or something. Sorry. What
would you like me to click on there?
On the on the left hand side, let's
click where wherever that what that spike was
in the on the blue line,
and then we can compare that to a
spike on the the right hand side.
Alright. We'll use what we have just now.
Interesting.
Okay. So in this case, we're actually seeing
something interesting.
We can pause here for a second. We're
seeing a bunch of memory addresses. Right? And
what we've just caught here is that Parca
hasn't actually been able to keep up with
all of the new data that we've been
sending to it,
and it does a process called symbolization.
And
one one of the employees at Polar Signals
came out. He just wrote a fantastic
blog post about what's happening
deep down
in in in this process.
But, essentially, the way that you can think
of
symbolization on a very high level is all
of these memory addresses is what we actually
captured from eBPF.
Right?
So eBPF
or the kernel
really only sees a stack being built.
And with eBPF, we're reading that entire stack.
But we're from from that kind of perspective,
we're not actually reading the function names or
something. We're only reading the offsets
of that code in our binary, and that's
basically what we're looking at here. And so,
hopefully, once we refresh,
Parca has had enough time
to
to get to to these memory addresses that
have not been symbolized yet and
can put some meaningful names for us humans
behind that.
Okay. Looks like something's wrong. I I I
can't can't say yet what. Maybe we can
jump over to
not doing the comparison,
and we can see if we can find
any of the
if we can find any any
symbols
for the new container.
Okay.
So if I just do this
That's just the Parca one, I think. Quite
hard. Yeah. You you you probably wanna
filter it down to
Name. The default namespace.
Yeah. Looks like looks like something about symbolization
is wrong. Maybe we can check out the
the logs of the Parca server to figure
out what's going on. Yeah. Some things appear
to be working. We could see that the
kernel space was actually correctly
symbolized.
If you I scroll down to here. We
can Yeah. We can see this is actually
something that also is incredibly cool about using
eBPF for this. If we're using a user
space profiler only like the ones that are
built into the Go runtime,
we would never be able to have this
depth of
detail.
Because from user space, we would never be
able to tell the kernel stack
that we we're currently in. But eBPF gives
us that kind of insight, which I think
is really,
really exciting because sometimes it is things that
are that far deep in in our
in our infrastructure that we need to understand
that there's some sort of maybe you know,
one of the most expensive things
on Linux machines is this context switch from
user space to kernel space or vice versa.
And if we can detect that this is
happening a lot,
then that's also incredibly
valuable performance information.
So
we were very excited when we got that
kind of detail of knowledge for the first
time.
Okay.
There's no logs on the Parca server.
Do we wanna look at the agent, or
do we wanna get Yeah. Yeah. We could
have a look at at the agent.
Is this gonna work?
I think it's the, like, canonical Kubernetes app
labeled, so it should be app.Kubernetes.io.
Okay. Alright. I'll just do a bot.
No.
Alright. I don't think we're gonna get anything
from there.
May as well do the last ones since
we've done two and three. Yep.
Okay. So the what happens here then is
when we do the search, we're trying to
look at this, is that what we get
by default is this object notation for something
that happened, and then Parca has to resolve
that to a name or a symbol, and
that process isn't happening here.
Yeah. So this is something that happens asynchronously
in the background.
When we when we upload the profiling data,
we actually all we're uploading are these memory
addresses,
and then Parca tries to symbolize them with
all of the new data that we're seeing.
And it seems like, for some reason, this
is stuck or it doesn't have the appropriate
information that it needs for this. Again, I
think this this format would probably we can
talk probably for six hours about how the
civilization stuff works.
Here here, this it appears to work. Not
sure why.
It could be the container image I've built.
This is the gigger one, and the the
symbols are definitely coming through okay.
But if we go to the container images
that I built, now is that is there
a way when I do a go build
that I am disabling?
And they say There there are there are
ways where you could potentially disable something like
this, and that that's very closely related to
how how this process works. So on a
on a on a high level, if we
think about,
what our binaries are made up of,
they're they're in a format called called ELF.
And an an ELF binary has various sections
that describe parts of the binary, basically.
Obviously, parts of it are are executable code,
but there are various other sections,
and one of them contains something that's called
DWARF debugging information.
And
this section,
sometimes people strip out of their binaries in
order to save space
of the size of the binary because the
executable code will still execute fine without dwarf
information,
but you may be,
you may be missing out on the ability
to debug. And there there are various
various case studies that all of the hyperscalers
essentially have done, and they always ended up
coming to the conclusion that it's not worth
throwing away this this information because Yeah. Being
able to debug is just always going to
be worth it.
I see you you did add a couple
of
compiler flags, so this might be the culprit,
but I I'm not
I don't know off the top of my
head what dash s and dash dash w
do. Yeah. These just came with the Dockerfile
for the project.
In fact, if I just go here may
as well just do the spoiler now and
show you. I haven't modified the Dockerfile. I
don't know what those flags do either. They
could very well that dash s being a
strip could be what's happening there.
But I just
decided it's a logical routine that that a
nice big blip. So that's why I've ever
seen that thing.
Yeah. Oh, wow. Nice. So I think we've
seen
a lot from Parca. I think we can
all see the value that it brings to
our infrastructure. I definitely do believe
that if you have a Kubernetes cluster in
production, that Parca should be part of that
stack because you just don't want to lose
the type of information that we're getting here,
especially when things go wrong and you need
as much information as possible.
And as you're deploying on a cloud native
way frequently,
multiple times per day, that compare feature is
just golden.
I had no idea we were gonna see
that and I'm so impressed and so excited
to get that running on my own customers
now. So thank you for that.
Yeah. My pleasure. I I think the first
time maybe Matthias remembers
this. He's he's in the in the comments.
The first time we were we, like, implemented
this, we were so mesmerized by this. We'd
like, I I think we spent, like, an
hour just clicking around
understanding just Parca itself. You know? Like, what
was what was the memory difference here and
why? Why why was this what's the CPU
spike?
And just, like, understanding that depth down to
the line number is just some not something
we've never seen before.
Yeah. So, yeah, I share the enthusiasm.
Sweet.
Matthias is in the comments saying that dash
s is probably the culprit. So
I will
I'm sure we'll do more demos. And if
you turn, we can take a look at
that. I'm
curious. You know, we'll we'll finish up now
in the next few minutes, but
kinda what your thoughts are on what's coming
next for Parca, what it takes for Parca
to to reach this next milestone,
whether that be, like, a one point o
or something else,
and
other crazy ideas that you've maybe got. So
let let's start with what's next for Parca.
Yeah. So
I think the
the
most important thing for the community that
we're working on with Parca is actually
the on the storage side.
As you can imagine, we're dealing with a
whole lot of data,
and it's it's not easy to deal with
that amount of data,
making it queryable,
as dynamically as we do with with Parca.
And, of course, the larger the scale, the
harder the steps.
And so
we're working on kind of a new storage
iteration
that's going to allow us to to scale
this to the to the size that we
intend at the query latency that we want.
So as we saw the the the demo
that the demo worked great, but if once
we go into the hundreds or thousands of
nodes,
with
thousands of containers,
it gets more difficult to to query that
data,
efficiently.
And so we're actually building an entirely custom
columnar store
just to solve this problem.
So that's something that I think is really
important to the success of this project
so that we can kind of scale the
entire idea.
So, yeah, that that's something that I'm also
personally very excited about because I think the
design and the design is open. You can
find
the the design on the
on the
I think it might have only been discussed
in the Parca office hours so far, but
it's open.
Nice.
Do you see a future where Parca integrates
with,
you know,
auto scalers on Kubernetes to be able to
you know, I can see, like, the vertical
pod auto scaler and been able to modify
those limits based on what Parca sees
and for that to evolve over time across
versions, even maybe to the point of hooking
into remediation systems, the captain, and actually reverting
a deploy based on bad behaviors or performance.
Yeah.
A %. So
as I said, the hyperscalers have been doing
methodologies like this for for almost a decade.
And, actually, eBPF is kind of the reason
why this is accessible to us now. Hyperscalers
have been maintaining
their operating system versions
themselves
for a long time, and that's why they
were able to do integrations like this at
a very low level that just the rest
of the world wasn't able to do. So,
like, was
really kind of a godsend for this.
But
what I was get trying to get to,
Google has actually written a couple of papers
where they described exactly what you just said
that they they use this type of data
for scheduling decisions in their orchestration system board.
And they they do various other
optimization techniques.
One that I'm particularly excited
about is something called profile guided optimizations.
And this is kind of a
technique that has existed, I believe, in my
in my research.
I I found it found found the first
kind of mentions in the in the nineteen
seventies.
And the premise is really simple because we
understand
how our programs are going to be executed
in real life, we can make opinionated compiler
optimizations
for exactly the those situations.
Optimizations that may not generally be a good
idea, but because we know how the this
code is going to be executed, we can
make opinionated optimizations.
And the the great news kind of is
these things do already exist in all major
compiler tool chains. And as a matter of
fact, the very next version of Go is
going to ship with profile guided optimizations,
possibilities as well.
So the the the great news for the
Parca project is kind of we don't even
need to build these mechanisms into compilers. They
already exist.
We just need to be able to export
this data in the format that these compilers
expect.
And then the the hope that we have
from all of this is that,
magically, just by giving your compiler some of
this data that you're collecting, hopefully, anyways now,
your programs just magically get faster, better, less
resources.
Awesome. That is all extremely exciting, and I
can't wait to follow along with the Parca
journey and just see what cool things come
out of this over the next six months
and longer. So thank you so much for
for joining us and guiding us through this.
It's been really cool. I think it's awesome
to be able to see these new techniques
and tools come out and make every hopefully,
make all of our lives that little bit
easier.
Any final words before we say goodbye for
today?
Just my my final words are please try
out Parca and
join us on our Discord server. If you
have any issues or any questions, feedback, anything,
we're more than happy
to, you know, help you through it. If
you have any issues or work through
feedback. We're always happy to to have any
kind of feedback
and and, you know, hope to improve Parca
together with the community.
Awesome.
Well, thanks again for joining me, Frederic. Have
a wonderful day, and I'll speak to you
again soon. My pleasure. Thank you for having
me.